Bây giờ, tổng thống Mỹ đôi năng tròm đào chíu viện trở ở Quay Nà không chỉ là phản đứng chức những diễn biến thực đia mà có nát kích quả của ý nhất năng quyền nhân thêm chốt.
Thuy nhất, Mui Kỳ sục đồ phòng tuyên kí ép sau ke đợ tấn công bằng UAV của Ngà, cho thấy ở Quay Nà không thể chú vấn nếu không được tiếp tế thêm vô khí phòng thu.
Đóng biết là tây lợ đánh trạng. Thưa hai, thông tin tình báo cho thấy hôm một chăm sóm như nghiệm quyền ngay đang dùng quan ở tiền tuyến,
gây ác lục lớn, bụng Mỹ phải tham thiệp để chẳng quý cơ khủng hoảng la dọc. Thưa bà, dơm từ việc Mỹ dút quân độc ngột khỏi ác cả nistan,
bắn còn là mạnh giữa hoạt đệnh chính xác đặc biệt là với đàn cập hoa.
Mù kịch bản tương tự tại UKNA sẽ vùng lớn tới hình ngành của chính quyền tổng thống Trump.
Thưa tư, có thể điệu cướng giám bởi tưởng á, bối xanh xác yêu cầu không thể chấm nhận đồ việc kế.
Chào thấy điện khem liên không còn mặt mà với đàn phán.
Thứ nằm bản thân tục thống Trump cũng muốn tạo sự khác biệt, bởi chính quyền tình nghiệm,
bởi giữ sữa linh hoạt đàn phán, bởi tránh biệt coi là MNBO với mask vã.
Bởi bà, viên cho quân sự chờ lại, là lựa trọn bắt bộ trong thể trợ để chính trị ngay cản sức cả.